hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game app from the penultimate
round of the video World rapid
Championship it is Norwegian Grandmaster
Johann Sebastian Christensen versus
Russian Grandmaster Vladimir burmakin
and if I just show you show you showed
you the game and I didn't tell you who's
playing it but it was from the world
rapid Championship you would say okay uh
probably dubo is playing white but nope
uh uh here is uh Johann Sebastian and
he's trying to take away dubo's Glory
with his crazy move so let's see what
happened here truly an amazing game uh
Johann Sebastian has the white pieces
and he opens with Knight to F3 he starts
off with dareti we have D5 and now c4 uh
uh sort of erratic Gambit but basically
transposing into an English opening we
have C6 G3 and now Knight to F6 with
Bishop to G2 Bishop to F5 and here we
have castles E6 now nicely closing the
structure with the light Square Bishop
already developed C capture C captures
sorry not c cap actress ecat person D5
and now Pawn to D3 with Bishop to E7
Knight to C3 and Knight beta D7 uh and
uh this this uh has all been played
before but here we have E4 sort of a
straight out Pawn sacrifice captures
captures and now uh there is a game
where Knight captures an E4 was played
the georgmeyer is the one who originally
uh played this E4 idea in 2019 against
Alexa and uh he was able to win that
game but here we don't have a cap [ __ ]
for we have Bishop to G4 pinning that
Knight and it is now as of move 10 that
we have a completely new game so let's
see uh What uh Johann Sebastian prepared
for this Ponte E5 uh and okay now how do
you claim this Pawn you will capture an
F3 it is definitely the best move
captures characters captures and now
just Knight captures and E5 so okay
black grabbed the pawn and now it's time
to prove that you can keep that pawn
queen to E2 now attacks the Knight
Knight back to G6 and now F4 okay white
is getting getting some attacking moves
in but nothing too spectacular we have
castles and now Pawn to F5 and this is
if this was a classical game of force
white would not play this but here white
should the black should take a moment
and try to refute this idea and in the
game this this did not happen here uh
Vladimir should have played Rook to E8
it comes with the thread of Bishop C5
check just winning the White Queen so
you have to play King to H1 and then
Bush up to f8 again attacks the queen
and wins the E5 Square for the Knight
and only once the queen moves you move
the knights to E5 and black is just
better here however as this is rapid
Bishop to C5 check was played seems like
you're doing the same thing only via a
different mover the problem is after
King to H1 now you no longer have Rook
E8 if you play rookie 8 now then just
Queen to C4 attacks the bishop and also
the Knight is hanging so black just
resigns here black will lose a piece so
uh Knight the E7 had to be played and
now look at this point to G4 uh White uh
a white attack is happening and it
should not even exist we have Knight eat
the D5 now and now Pawn to G5 and okay
since white decided to go for an all our
attack it is very principled to remove
as many pieces from the board from from
Black's perspective so Knight captures
on C3 that Knight might also be a
valuable attacker at some point and also
you clear the D5 Square for your other
Knight that is attacked on F6 so B
captures on C3 and now Knight to D5 and
here just C4
chasing away that knight from uh from uh
even just the vicinity of the black king
we have Knight the B4 and here again uh
if black had a moment uh to check out
what was happening Bishop to D4 is just
great for black attacks the rook and the
white would have to continue the attack
with C captures on D5 and give up the
exchange because if you try to save the
Rogue then Knight the C3 now uh wins the
the game for black so uh Knight the B4
was played and now comes Bishop to B2 uh
putting pressure on this long diagonal
and now uh uh here the G5 Pawn is
hanging but do you really want to
capture this G Pawn if you don't capture
it then Queen to H5 comes in the next
move and all this pressure going towards
the black king will be very hard to
Parry so Queen captures and G5 was
played and okay it seems like you cannot
play Rook to G1 because the bishop
covers that square but uh that never
stopped an attacker from attacking so
Rook to G1 and the just Queen to H6
black does not want to capture this Rook
until he absolutely needs to
and uh well you have to move the Queen
off of this diagonal because once the
bush the light Square Bishop moves uh
there will be trouble so Queen to H6
pretty much the only Square you have
left and now comes Bishop to D5 the move
from the thumbnail I will just show you
a fun line that starts with Bishop
captures and G7 well this is possible uh
it is also possible to defend this for
black now King characters and G7 Queen
to E5 check now F6 and queen captures
and C5 looks pretty good attacks the
Knight lets the Knight to S6 A6 but now
Queen to E7 check you cannot play Rook
to F7 because once the bishop moves you
will lose that Rook on F7 so you have to
move the king now we're gonna capture
here attack the Knight and once the
Knight attacks the queen you're gonna
capture on C6 and uh White definitely
has enough uh for for for compensation
white is up a pawn and uh okay it's not
too much maybe Knight D3 going after a
smarter than mate here so white will
have to defend this 95 and okay that
this maybe would be the resulting
position is pretty much all forced but
not too much for white here he does have
a past C Pawn whether he would be able
to you know nurture that to to a queen
we would have to see but here Bishop to
D5 instead and this is much much
trickier as it allows black to just
completely blunder the game away as it
happened in the game so here okay now I
have to capture on G1 uh even if you
don't calculate anything you just think
to yourself okay if I survive the attack
I'm just going to be at material so
Bishop captures on G1 Rook captures on
G1 and this is where it happens now just
in case you're wondering G6 is not a
possibility just Queen E5 and you cannot
prevent Checkmate you cannot Advance the
F Pawn the F Pawn is pin so this is just
game over so instead after Rook captures
on G1 we have C captures on D5 and we're
gonna return to this position once I
show you the actual game but C
characters and D5 is the move that
completely blunders the game away for
black but it's not easy to see why
there's only one move that wins the game
for white so for free to pause the video
and win the game for Johann Sebastian
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
absolute brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Queen to H5 we are of course going to do
it in super slow motion as the queen
cannot be accepted the problem is uh if
you capture here then look at this Rook
captures on G7 check King h8 now Rook
captures an F7 with check this is a very
important uh part of your plan as you
want to eliminate the F1 so black cannot
use it in the future to block check with
Pawn to F6 so now you have only one
option King to G8 okay you can even give
up the D4 Pawn First doesn't really
change anything uh King to G8 now again
Rook the G7 check King to h8 and now
Rook the G6 with check uh leaving black
without any squares for the king and
you've eliminated the df7 pawn so black
cannot block this check with so you're
gonna have to give up the pawn and then
give up the look and this is just
Checkmate so unfortunately for uh for
Vladimir it is impossible to capture
this queen so but there's no way to
actually avoid losing the queen because
if you move the queen somewhere we're
just through captress on G7 check and
queen captures on H7 will be Checkmate
so he played king a queen to G6 sort of
a way to prolong the game a little bit
but it'd be it'd be way nicer if he just
resigned here and then we could have
this as the final position but okay he
played a few more moves Queen to G6 uh
the queen is captured H captors and G6
and now Queen to E5 threatening
Checkmate here F6 we have Queen to E6
check Rook to F7 in here just The Rook
captures on G6 and he was in this
position on a move 29 that Vladimir
bullmakin resigned in the game as there
is nothing more to be done here uh now
the the G Pawn is pinned The Rook is
pinned Bishop captures on F6 is coming
uh you cannot unpin here with the King
if you move the king to a f8 the then
just Queen to D6 check will pick up the
Knight here you cannot move the king to
the H file because this Rook will hang
so there really isn't all that much now
you can do here if Rook to f8 you can
even play Bishop to A3 also very nice I
mean so many moves here the the spawn is
marching up the board uh the the it's
completely unplayable so a big big game
by Johann Sebastian it's a bit uh it's
okay it's not maybe up to do both
standards as Dubose win against the
Geary uh I mean giri is a much much
stronger opponent and he did do it with
the black pieces uh but in terms of of
beauty and in terms of style uh
definitely uh you know uh uh a worthy
game of your time beautiful beautiful
attacking game and I would just like to
return to that moment where I said that
we are going to return to it here where
C captures and D5 was played uh grabbing
that Bishop if black played Knight
captures on D5 it would be completely
different because now even though Queen
to H5 can still be played or even must
if white wants to continue uh with
something then uh there is no Checkmate
Queen captures on H5 and now the same
idea no longer works Rook captures on G7
King h8 Rook characters on F7 with check
King to G8 Rook G7 check King h8 and now
some Rook so now you have to play Rook
to F7 check and go for a repetition
because if you try the same idea uh now
it's not Checkmate because Knight can
block with Knight to F6 and now the
white is just down too much material
white will have to resign uh so yeah uh
very very nice stuff and okay for a
classical maybe you wouldn't be able to
pull this off but for a rapid game uh
definitely uh uh a beautiful attacking
game with many pawns gambited and the
many many tricky ideas
uh so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys uh enjoyed it uh we've already
reached the final round of the uh video
World rapid Championship where uh the
tournament is being led by Magnus cross
and vladislavartame uh and Vincent kymer
and we'll see what happens uh in the
final round who will be crowned the
world rapid Champion 2022 but until then
hope you enjoyed this and I'll see you
in the next video uh and also I would
like to thank Jeff Graves David Rock
arise Oxley Kevin Clark Chris Mullen and
Rapid boss for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on defeated World
rapid Championship until it finishes uh
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day